there is actually no physical anything
found on the premises it was someone
used our IP address to access something
in August
kiss rocker gene Simmons Los Angeles
home was searched by police to discuss a
crime that possibly occurred on the
property while Simmons was away on tour
authorities were looking for evidence of
child pornography since day one the LAPD
has strongly maintained Simmons nor any
of his family members were suspects
telling et the family was quote
extremely cooperative the musicians 23
year old daughter Sophie recently opened
up to et about the incident so it was
more of like a hacking situation than it
was anything physical because there
wasn't actually anything physical in our
house I feel like we would have noticed
right but so well yeah someone someone
used our IP address or our Wi-Fi to
access something which is a relatively
easy thing to do I'm not gonna ask you
who but do you know who is responsible
no I think the case has moved on from
our family because we've given the names
of everyone we've ever had in the house
and I don't think anything was found the
situation was particularly emotional for
Sophie who has a shelter for abused
children in Vancouver called Sophie's
place you let people into your home
thinking that you know who they are and
to find out that someone's abused that
trust is